Rob Kardashian and blac Chyna are in no  rush to say I do the couple hosted a day  party at the sky beach club at tropicana  las vegas on saturday where ET was the  only one to talk to the pair about their  wedding plans blac chyna showed off her  baby bump in a figure fitting dress  while Rob looked happy and healthy  smiling next to his bride-to-be the 28  year old model revealed to ET quote were  taking things slow when it comes to  planning their upcoming nuptials and Rob  completely gushed about his lady telling  us she is his priority quote I'm just  chilling and making sure she straight a  source close to China tells ET the  wedding will most likely be a grand  occasion explaining that since the  proposal was big it's clear Rob likes  big gestures  china even gushed about how all is well  with the Kardashian family everyone's  happy things with Rob's family are  fantastic  you